(dubstep beat)
(grunting and gagging)
- Just too, buku?
Is this way too bu ku?
Gahhhhhhh!
- [Video Game] Go, go, go!
- Oh God, I can't believe
Kid Lightning's dead.
He was my best friend, even though he was
a total dick to me.
(crying)
He was so young. Or old. Just
don't know what I can do.
- You're not helping.
You're making this sadder.
- You probably deal with
it in your own way and...
- I masturbate. You can say it.
- You masturbate.
- Hey, toe cheese lovers. What's up?
Let's play man, I'm psyched.
Play.
- Listen, before you came in
we were talking about grief processes.
- [Doctor Flashback] Yeah.
- And clearly you're dealing
with this with humor, but--
- Dealing with what?
- Kid Lightning.
- Yeah, what about him?
- He's dead.
- Really?
- How do you not know this?
- I'm off the grid.
- He died three days ago.
- It's a really big grid.
(battle sounds)
- What happened? He was so young-old.
- I heard from a very reliable source,
national public radio,
you should all donate.
- Oh boy.
- He died fighting his
arch-rival, Shrewd Shrew,
who was trying to use a
quantum cube to open up a
gateway to a hell dimension.
In order to distract Kid
Lightning he placed a
busload of MILFs, a bang bus if you will.
- Yeah, he likes that.
- Kid Lightning had to close
the gate to the hell dimension
but also to save the teetering MILFs.
- He's a multi-tasker.
- [Big Chill] I mean, he was
able to destroy the cube but
it weakened him and he was
crushed by the bang bus.
- Oh man, that is
- wow, that is
- Terrible.
- An amazing story.
If it were true,
which it's not
- What do you mean?
- I have a different story.
I was in Peru doing Ayahuasca
with my Shaman friend, Mike
- [Complacent Man] Oh wow
- [Doctor Flashback] On
my fourth hour of tripping
a king snake came to me
and told me that Kid
Lightning got his dick
stuck in his zipper a week ago.
- [Complacent Man] Oh man.
- He died of a dick infection.
- That must be true then.
- [Big Chill] No, I don't--
- Forget that bus shit.
- I'm sorry, I just don't
trust your flashbacks anymore.
- Remember when you said Abraham Lincoln
- [Together] Only farted, he never talked.
- Yeah, I stick by that one.
(explosion)
- I've got the best arbiter of facts here,
world star hip hop, I'm gonna look it up.
- You're going to a
website that specializes
in Denny's parking lot fights.
- [Complacent Man] Oh, here it is.
Kid Lightning did enormous amount of cokes
off Al Roker's head
and had a heart attack.
- I do not think that's true.
- It's true, look!
(notification beep)
- Wow.
- Lightning just signed in.
- My eyes, my eyes.
- Whoah, whoah.
- Okay, let's invite him to the game.
We have to see if
- Okay, I'm sending him
this is him or not.
- an invite right now.
Here we go.
- Maybe it's him, maybe
he came back to life.
Maybe a super hero came back to life.
- We'll see.
- He's a ghost.
- That happens a lot.
- [Doctor Flashback] Here he comes.
- Lightning, is that you?
- Uh, no.
- Who the fuck are you then?
- Whoah, man, my name's Zeke.
I'm Lightning's roommate.
- Oh, hey Zeke.
- Hi.
- While we have you here, which is weird,
- [Zeke] Yeah?
- Maybe you can settle
and argument for us.
How did Kid Lightning die?
- There's been some debate.
- Well, I know.
- You guys don't...
Oh yeah, he got, It's weird,
he got struck by lightning.
- That...That's--
- Wow, really?
- [Big Chill] Sorry.
it's a little funny.
- No way.
- It's a little bit funny.
- It is funny.
- While masturbating with
a plastic bag on his head.
- oh, that's less funny.
(dubstep beat)